c'est officiel en 2021 tf1 a décidé de
mettre toutes les chances de son côté
pour gagner quelques parts de marché
c'est en tous les cas ce qu'on peut en
conclure quand on sait que cette année à
la télé ce sera double dose de koh lanta
c'est pas énorme faim d'abord au
printemps les téléspectateurs pourront
découvrir la 22e saison du programme une
saison tournée au moment du confinement
en polynésie pour faire monter la
pression tf1 a diffusé les premières
images de cette émission déjà très
attendu il faut dire que pour tf1 koh
lanta c'est le jackpot
durant le premier confirmant le
programme avait affiché des scores très
haut avec régulièrement des scores au
dessus des 7 millions de téléspectateurs
c'est bon pour le moral et pour être
sûrs de ne rien rater tf1 a décidé de
diffuser cette année une double dose de
koh lanta
en effet la chaîne et alp serait en
train de préparer une édition all stars
c'est la septième fois que koh lanta
propose une édition spéciale avec
d'anciens candidats emblématiques du
programme
une façon de s'assurer de bonnes
audiences toute l'année au risque de
saturer alors les premières images de
koh lanta
craignez-vous l'overdose quand est-ce
que c'est trop non non oui oui alors moi
je pense que trop de koh lanta l'aurait
d'avoir l'avis des téléspectateurs aussi
la tuerie moi je pense que trop de koh
lanta dessus koh lanta le groupe prenne
de tf1 c'est qu'ils ont qu une seule
marque de divertissement qui surperforme
après que tu es maintenant je n'ai fait
un petit tableau des oignons c'est que
koh lanta en moyenne qui dépasse les 6
millions de téléspectateurs
nadal 6 millions c'est énorme oui mais
en dalles ça marche plus nigeria
orientale c'est pas ça c'est que ça
après c'est pas gagné mieux même les
saisons avant ils ont plus de marquer
mais ce ninja ou ailleurs c'est pareil
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'il trouve
une masse singer sa fédé ça fait quatre
et demi donc c'est pas mal hein le russe
avant il faisait si mignons les grosses
marques comme danse avec les stars à
l'époque ça faisait 6 millions nissan
qui trouve une où tu m'as koh lanta ça
fait 6,1 sur la dernière saison
koh lanta c'est une enfant qui trouve
une autre marque comme koh lanta parce
que si metro koh lanta ça risque de
lasser les téléspectateurs je pense
pascal non moi j'ai dit qu'il a seront
jamais parce que c'est la seule émission
qui part quand tu fais jouer des
inconnus et ça ça plaira toujours et
avec des paysages magnifiques comme ici
la raison n'a pas de raison de s'en
lasser sûr que l'adrénaline elle est
plus importante quand on n'a pas vu
l'émission pendant sept huit mois on est
là on attend ça explose après par contre
au fait effectivement il ya 6 millions
mais faut pas oublier qu'il ya des 6
millions 7 millions depuis quelques du
confinement
sinon on est à trois et demi 4 1
versez les seniors star d'appui de
combat dayraut quatre et demi j'ai bleus
alors catherine sais j'ai regardé depuis
2009 1,7 million leur chienne les quatre
autres serpents régressé après le combat
des héros c'est redescendu à il ya eu du
3 et demi quatre morts trois nient pas
que c'était à mon avis les moyens on
t'attend il faut regarder un colon
chaque année c'est ça oui pascal il faut
regarder la moyenne de la saison c'est
marco est là juste là c'est 4,9 et les
oies qui lance la saison
on sent là on peut pas s'en lasser parce
que d'abord il ya que ça déjà c'est
important et comparé aux autres
émissions où ils prennent des gens
toujours connu on voit toujours les
mêmes
voilà c'est pas excitant la sas on peut
pas pour moi on peut pas s'en lasser
alors possible il ya un koh lanta all
star est ce qu'on vous pourrez vous
appelez pascal pour un koh lanta le star
ou pas du tout ce que vous avez
pour moi on peut pas m'appeler pour
divers raisons c'est que je suis
black-listé puisque j'ai fait de la télé
réalité ce que je ne regrette pas du
tout ensuite parce que vous avez fait en
télé réalité j'ai fait les anges
exactement voilà ce que je regarde pas
c'est un très bon mois une belle
expérience j'aurais également hier je
remplis marc disque dur donc si c'est
haro faire voilà ça ce que vous êtes
valorisé par la production de men tous
ceux qui font de la télé réalité mais
bon on le sait à l'avancé on nous dit
attention vous partez faire la terre
étaient ses films définit donc vous y
allez après faut pas le regretter
d'accord ensuite je suis black je suis
black-listé parce que j'ai eu des gros
problème est que la production
s'affaisser à au ccdh avait fait de ces
communs à tout le monde on le sait donc
déjà après le problème quel genre de
problèmes sur les montages d'image on le
sait que sur chaque saison c'est de pire
en pire de toute façon c'est à dire
c'est que les montages images c'est à
dire que là-bas vous faites des
situations et dans le montage d'image
c'est pas du tout les mêmes situations
vous fait passer alors vous aimez
remarquer chaque saison vous avez le
gentil le méchant ya toujours un mais ça
c'est normal
oui c'est comme si tu avais dit ouais
mais ça c'est de la télé tu fais de la
clé mais on ne sait pas nous quand on
fait koh lanta quand on va faire koh
lanta genou la télé c'est pas notre
notre fonds de commerce
on arrive et on nous voit la télé on
voit un conseil qui mais c'est pas ça je
passe pour un pont pour un gros con ça
fait mal avec le montage on peut
vraiment changer la personnalité
complètement
oui enfin il faudra qu'on complètement
téléspectateurs ses nombreux écarts
pascal c'est normal que chacun ait un
rôle il faut ajouter la dir soient
claires du storytelling aujourd'hui si
vous regardez besoin qu'un canadien
celui qu'on aime bien il ya celui qui
est sexy ya celui de koh lanta d'avant
ça a changé depuis que des motifs une
émission il ya celui qu'on aime bien oui
c'est sexy n'ont mené aucun des douilles
vides avec sa large ou bears a
complètement changé complètement évolué
c'est comme les inspirations vision non
par les eaux à l'excès et puis 6
millions en france un périple entamé un
téléspectateur sur neuf le joueur que de
koh lanta quel fan de l'aventuré ils
regardent la télé du à cheval et choix
et je veux crever de faim je veux bien
mais il pour lui
koh lanta n'était pas n'est pas collé à
la télé réalité
certes on est en plein dedans maintenant
mais dans la tête d'ailleurs on disait à
nantes a fait koh lanta va pas les hors
jeu ne fait pas la pénalité tapée koh
lanta mais c'est de la télé réalité mais
quand on a affaire collante et on
s'attend pas ça c'est changement d'image
non je suis pas d'accord mais pascal
pascal juste est ce que le montage vous
délivre avec des problèmes avec la
production à cause du montage est ce que
ça t'a ça a été préjudiciable pour tout
auprès de la famille préjudice à vous il
parce que préjudiciable oui parce que
quand tu étais ta famille tu t'y attends
pas que du jour au lendemain on envoie
des ajouté personne même chez toi pour
pas les nommer pour faire du buzz qui
s'envoyait par la production alors que
la production nous disent surtout à
l'épaté pmp vous parlez pas à nous la
vous y allez pas alors c'est ce que dit
la production c'est ce que tu me l'a
complètement new directions lp ok alors
on va dire en fait ce qui est très drôle
et je le dis franchement d'autant plus
ça me fait rire barakat et vous pouvez
le dire non mais c'est la même boîte que
ce qui produit de tp oui mais c'est un
gros ils le savent
voilà 11010 quoi ils vous ont dit ne va
jamais dont il ne va jamais la braquage
dû attendre des tartes à la crème ok
tout le monde on sait c'est c'est eux
qui mènent à ils ont du mal à tenir mais
de plus en plus ils tiennent et à une
époque on tenait encore un peu les
joueurs il y en avait pas le waf est ce
que c'est vrai pascal que si qui vous
donne une partie de l'argent et que si
vous parlez aussi à la clause de
confidentialité évidemment ça et vous
donne une autre partie après il ya une
partie qui est fliqué de qe2 ne
s'intéressant l'émission est terminée
d'accord site à respecter que t'as pas
balancer des dédaignant dans un camion
tout ça
non mais moi ce qui m'étonne c'est qu'il
vous lisez de ne pas aller dans tpm p
les candidats au coude je ne comprends
pas tu dis on a des joueurs de palets
atp depuis des années tu as un joueur
qui vient parler de son salaire donc
gros bordel tu es à faa'a à la fois où
c'était dylan qu'elle lui a donné son
salaire enfin voilà village
il a donc auquel il donne son salaire
donc gros bordel dylan map était affable
me massacrer hockey et la semaine
d'après revient avec la sim mais je
comprends pas bien cela alexia
laroche-joubert j mais pourquoi vous
laisser venir sachant qu'on doit pas y
aller qui a eu un bordel parce qu'il est
envoyé pour faire du buzz c'est du
google tous les jours koh-lanta
aujourd'hui ça d'accord aujourd'hui
c'est du google tout le temps ce qui
vous dit qu'il vous dit de ne pas venir
la peur de la tâche mais quelque part
ils ont raison parce que quand on vient
là oui on est des amateurs on connaît
pas la télé on arrive là on est face à
vous on est là en perm en trop les gens
qui vous disent ils vous disent ne pas y
aller parce qu'ils vont ils ont peur de
la fuite de gaz et des questions si
elles sont plus au piège ou pas piège
mon père dit les pédales et ça peut
lancer une bombe c'est sûr voilà d'après
là on affine aparté je veux pas en
parler de lui bien sûr de 2018 on s'en
fout mal an c'est fini voilà mais tu me
dis all-star non je repartirai pas parce
qu'ils veulent parce que vous avez
traîné all star ou pas du tout guillaume
genton parler des candidats avec
beaucoup de personnalité dans koh lanta
et la dernière saison elle a été
beaucoup critiqués parce que les
candidats manqué de personnalité
platement il ya un détail dans la
bande-annonce qui m'a un peu intrigué
c'est qu'ils disent après deux saisons
mythique et on voit que des images n'ont
pas de l'année 1 saison mais la saison
de claude et la saison encore avant s'il
assume et pas la dernière saison
pourquoi plutôt pas mal marché a très
bien marché mais c'est vrai qu'a été
beaucoup moins forte que la saison avec
toi lorsque c'est une erreur simplement
c'est moi c'est une erreur dans le
teaser tout simplement ses sabots
d'accord il ne faut pas chercher midi
parce qu'ils sont passés identifiable
cela et quand ils ont montré des images
de ce qu'était le plus en mémoire tout
bêtement
et puis les autres sont plus proches de
nous donc savait moins d'intérêt alors
est ce qu'on le connaît l'overdose 1 sur
koh lanta à regarder on va voir ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs oui à 44%
non à 56 %
moi je veux dire mon sentiment je pense
que c'est une erreur de faire deux
saisons
parce que moi je suis j'adore kolontar
voilà mais je pense que voilà un moment
j'espère qu'on va qu'on va parler à
chaque fois avec koh lanta a marseille
deux saisons par an oh oui
beaucoup mieux que les rameurs mon nom
mais sa manière qu'à un moment on se
dise on voit que koh lanta pris moi si
je me trompe mais on vend de la
publicité au site à ma nation et yakuza
5 6 millions de spectateurs tuant plus
de pub cabinet micha bien sûr millions
masure sert il ya des bons d'ailleurs
faux de saison 1 ne bouge à la vingt
troisième en préparation la science à
des questions de holanda je vous le dis
je crois que si on est encore pour deux
ans sur tf1 c'est à peu près je vous le
dis ça coûte
tf1 1,2 à 1,3 million l'épisode wii
delphine et des fans inconditionnels de
koh lanta donc pourquoi ne pas le faire
chaque année d'ailleurs ça la même boîte
de production alp que fort boyard assuré
marc boilard ça fait maintenant une
trentaine d'années que ça existe donc
pourquoi pas souhaiter la même chose à
colin et la douane et chiale paix fort
boyard est ce qui vous ont dit de ne pas
venir dans tpp non si oui donnez moi les
notes du goûte qui est incroyable pardon
je reprends juste c'est c'est grâce à la
promo de fort boyard quand j'étais
baigner à deux ans que après exactement
ni chroniqueuse au clin d'oeil après
cette escalade de l'europe ce que vous
ne m'avez pas souhaité l'anonymat